- My friends, if you do not spend 2018
completely and obsessively
around Facebook and Instagram,
you will lose.
(soft music)
Toys "R" Us did two things
over the last couple decades
that make no sense.
One, very early in the 2000's
they outsourced themselves to Amazon.
They didn't believe in the internet,
17 years ago said let
Amazon do their fulfillment.
Which started people
getting used to buying toys
on the internet through an Amazon world.
But most importantly,
they just didn't innovate.
And when you don't innovate, you die.
Like when you don't change you die.
The world passes you by.
It's the best example right now
of how in trouble everybody is
if they fuckin' rest on their laurels.
If Toys "R" Us, the
dominant niche retail leader
of a humongous multi-billion
dollar category, is finished,
what do you think is gonna
happen over the next six years?
This is a calm before
the social media storm.
This is 2000 all over again.
The internet came out,
it had a lot of hype,
the market crashed,
people didn't see returns
and people left it.
Borders didn't believe in it,
they gave Amazon the infrastructure,
they're out of business.
Blockbuster didn't believe in it,
they let Netflix come in and
put them out of business.
Social media has had a lot
of hype the last two years,
the next three are gonna be soft
because people are not
gonna figure out the ROI
and then people are gonna
be put out of business
and huge businesses are gonna blow up
and explode and take over in 2013, 14, 15.
- Wow.
- Yeah, that's what's happenin'.
We have a room of
professionals in this room
who say, well my customers
not on Facebook or Instagram,
maybe they're on LinkedIn.
That is the exact same rationale
that Netflix put Blockbuster
out of business with.
Blockbuster sat in a room and they said,
our data shows that people
like going to our stores.
By the way, are you really ready to laugh?
Here's what the report actually said,
they like the experience
of going to our stores
because they like the
ability to open and close
and read the back of the DVD cases.
It gets better, they enjoy the serendipity
of possibly running into their neighbor.
This is what the report, by the way,
that's my favorite part
about reports and data,
when you have an agenda
you can make a report
do a anything you want.
Thank you.
And then finally, they
really like picking up
popcorn on the way out.
I don't know about you guys,
but here is the experience I like,
laying naked in my bed and
pressing one fuckin' button.
(audience laughing)
Like, social time at the store, really?
Like, that's not gonna play out.
Like, it's just not gonna play out.
You'll find other things to do.
There's not gonna be a
single convenience store
in America in 20 years.
Like 7/11's out of business.
You're not gonna go there.
You're just not.
You're gonna get
everything within an hour.
Everything, on demand, ad hoc,
at the lowest possible cost,
you will not believe it.
We hold the past on a pedestal
and we demonize the future.
Like that's just not how it works.
And this internet thing,
you're sleeping on it.
It's bigger than you think.
This is it.
This is the television
and radio of our society.
The internet has won, there is no debate,
you may not like it, it
doesn't matter what you think.
Guys, ABC and CBS and
ESPN are out of business.
It's already over.
80 billion dollars, you can
sit cause I gotta wrap up.
80 billion dollars in
television commercials
and nobody fuckin' watches them.
Over the next three or four to five years,
the biggest companies in the
world are gonna understand that
that money is gonna go into the shit
that I just told you about.
That's gonna mean the
ads that you're gonna run
are gonna go from $4.00 to $80.00
and you're not gonna be able
to compete with Coca-Cola and BMW.
So please heed what I told you
and take your romance or
your subjective point of view
or you being romantic about
how the world used to be
and shove that shit in the garbage
and get to fuckin' work.
One life, do something about it.
(audience cheering and applauding)